so when you were talking about a while
ago you said like in sixth grade or
seventh grade that you wanted to be a
rock set was that right mm-hmm you wrote
this thing out saying i want to be a
rock set at
whatever years old and now how old
before you get your audition for the
rock sets rock sets rock set broadcast
did i say do you know why because you
know why because roxat is one of my
favorite 80s bands and i keep saying it
remember that song she's got the look
what in the world can make a bright
apple turn blue oh yeah good song you
say sorry so not rock set the rock cats
no it's okay
um yes it's the rock cats yes so um
the rockettes i have first auditioned
for the rockets when i was going to
school
in new york
i auditioned for the national tour of
the rockettes because at the time
there was the radio city
crew and then there were rockettes and
all these other cities doing the
christmas show in st louis or in
columbus or chicago
so i thought i would go to those
auditions and maybe have a better chance
at getting that job first
and i got cut and then i went back again
to another audition it got cut and so my
third audition again was for the actual
radio city rockets
and that was while i was on tour with
42nd street
and um i flew from la to new york to
that audition spent two days
it was like a thousand girls there they
needed 12 and after two days i ended up
getting done those high kicks i mean how
hard is that to get those kicks right
and what was it in the first two
auditions that you think
that they give you notes like well you
know your heels to the right uh too much
i don't know what you do you're doing
something wrong they tell you what
you're doing wrong so you can come back
and correct it oh yeah your head was um
it's it's uh
you know they'll say like looking to the
sun so like your chin is like you're
looking to the sun
but if it's this way you're like you
know your chin was an inch low so you
got to lift it up or you know your pinky
was out so you put it in i mean it is so
detailed
i mean it's all about you know being
uniform so you have to be like it's
precision precision dance at its best
you're like a marine you're like the
marines it's like everything has to be
precise yeah the goal the goal of the
rockets is to not stick out right you
don't want to be an individual you want
to be one of 36.
so the heart honestly the hardest thing
about the kicks is that you have to kick
its eye high so your toe to your eye so
it can't be higher it can't be lower
so it's not necessarily it's not like oh
my gosh is it so hard to kick your your
do the high high do the high kicks
it's more so you have to hit a target
that is like right in front of you that
is like a laser beam that no one else
can see except you know your imagination
and
that's i think that's the hardest part
about the kicks was that though
go ahead
oh that into like when i was a rocket i
did five shows in one day so it was you
know you're doing
you know a ridiculous amount of of uh
activity
i mean i i guess the first time you
auditioned you just it was like you were
kicking you were just trying to
in a way you're probably trying to stand
out when you weren't supposed to stand
out no i knew not to stand out um my
first two auditions i just i
you have to learn it's a process
you just you know and it's intimidating
you're auditioning at the grand hall at
radio city musical there's a lot of
girls everybody looks the same because
it's again about having a certain look
and height
um
so i think it was just about like
learning and being confident and and
getting super sharp in your dancing and
you know you have to be good and i just
i wasn't good enough the first two times